winter is coming and [ __ ] just got real
Game of Thrones Season three Episode
four and now his watch has ended this
one really built on the momentum that
got started up in the third one and
thankfully that foundation building from
the first few episodes proving to be
completely worth it because now it feels
like we're moving at breakneck speed
that's not to say this this episode is
wall-to-wall action though there's a bit
more of it that we've had in other
episodes but it's just stuff is finally
happening whether it's big moments with
swords and battles or Squire moments
between two characters walking through a
garden which actually is probably some
of my favorite stuff in this episode
when you get to scheming characters just
trying to feel each other out and get a
sense of each other I actually kind of
enjoy that almost more than the sword
fights just because it's it's a mental
game and it's a mental battle and like
well they're each trying to get
something from each other but they also
don't want to give up too much and
watching someone like Lorde virus who
we've known for a while spar off against
Diana Rigg and completely meet his match
with her all that is good and actually
with Lord Varys we got quite a bit of
insight and I always get weary when we
get a lot of backstory on what had been
effectively side carriage is up to this
point because it's always supposed to
make them deeper and more interesting
but it mines experience more often than
not it just sort of makes you oh ho okay
I kind of liked it better when I didn't
really know why they were like that but
with him it was such a dark and ominous
backstory to his character it contrasts
with his outward appearance in his way
of going about things in such a fun way
that it really makes you think a lot
harder about him especially with what
happens at the end of that scene I'm
really loving lady Margaery Joffrey's
new queen cuz we're watching her
manipulate him and we know she's
manipulating him but she's so good at it
usually when you're watching something
and a character's manipulating another
and you know that's what's happening
it's not like gonna be a twist later on
down the road when you know the
manipulation is going on it usually just
feels so clunky and it makes the person
being manipulated look like an idiot
it's like how can you not
see that they are manipulating the hell
out of you she is so good and so natural
and so easy going in her manipulations
you completely by that Joffrey just
grows with it it makes her look awesome
as opposed to making him look more
stupid Tywin Lannister get some more
awesome moments laying the smackdown on
some more people who have kind of
deserved it up to this point we touch
base to get with Theon Greyjoy who's
having a really rough go over right now
and I really kind of feel sorry for him
because he doesn't belong anywhere and
that you really gets emphasized in this
episode very effectively and then
there's everything that goes on with the
Nights Watch and it's interesting to see
this group that up to this point all the
emphasis has been on brotherhood and
loyalty and wow let's not forget this is
a group made up of people who for the
most part had no choice but to join so
when the chips are down are they all
gonna ban together it's nice to see that
played out here however absolute
highlight of isms a generis she is
finally becoming consistently the
character that I was excited to watch
her become her trajectory as a character
was pretty obvious from season one where
she was headed so it always frustrated
me in season two and the early parts of
this season where she got these major
stumbles that were stalling her from
getting to where I know she's gonna end
up and where I want to see her get well
she's there she is so badass in this
episode and everything that happens with
her and the and in slavers Bay is just
awesome and gets your adrenaline pumping
here like I want more I can't wait to
keep these going so we get a bit more of
the Dragons this time so on that basis
let me ask you what's your favorite
dragon from TV or film leave something
in the comments let's talk about it and
until next time this council is
adjourned